breaking news here at five o'clock a  child hit and killed in a neighborhood  near charleston and hollywood we thank  you for joining us here at five i'm  denise valdez and i'm brian loftis we  want to get right to madison kimbrough  madison is at the scene now joining us  live with more  denise and brian that child was taken to  sunrise trauma they later passed away we  don't know the age of the child but you  can look behind me it's still a very  active scene there's a lot of police  activity in this neighborhood it  happened on pave stone lane on this  short street only about 10 homes it's  unclear what exactly happened so we're  still waiting for more details from  police all we know so far is that a  child was hit by a vehicle and that  metro's fatal detectives responded to  the scene again a big police presence in  this residential neighborhood luckily  there are no traffic delays in this area  at this time reporting in the east  valley madison kimbrough live local now